>> Hi, I'm Mario.
>> And I'm Samantha.
>> And my name's Andy, and we're going to be the instructors for this class.
>> And you're a person looking for a job, or
maybe you have an idea that you want to turn into
an app, or maybe you just want to learn more about
what Salesforce is, what it can do, and how it works.
>> You may never have heard of Salesforce before, or you might already
be a developer looking to brush up on your point and click skills.
>> Maybe you have zero programming
experience, or maybe you're an experienced programmer
just looking to brush up a bit on how to build some new apps.
>> Regardless, by the end of this
class, you'll have built a fully functional,
robust, web and mobile app, without writing
a single line of code. That's awesome.